Wenn du einen Entmietungskamps
führst , egal ob du ihn gewinnst oder ob du
verlierst, du wirst einfach
traumatisiert. Ich habe im Lauf der letzten Jahre so
viele Menschen kennengelernt, die wirklich
in permanenter Angst leben. Und das geht
-so einfach nicht.
-Hallo und herzlich Willkommen! Ich freue
mich sehr auf die Diskussion und starte
direkt mit der ersten Frage von 13 Fragen,
mit unserer Konfliktfrage: Muss der Staat
stärker in den Wohnungsmarkt eingreifen?
Wenn ihr sagt: Ja, er muss stärker
eingreifen, um bezahlbares Wohnen jetzt
und auch in der Zukunft möglich zu machen,
dann geht ihr aufs grüne Feld.
Und wenn ihr sagt: nNein, er sollte
echt nicht stärker eingreifen, dann geht
ihr aufs gelbe Feld. Dann könnt
ihr euch jetzt gerne positionieren. Okay,
eure Positionen sind damit klar.
Kommen wir zum Thema: Immobilienspekulation,
Wohnungsmangel, immer weiter
steigende Mieten – der Wohnraum in Deutschland ist
rar umkämpft und für viele
unbezahlbar. Wie also schaffen wir in Zukunft
bezahlbaren Wohnraum für alle? Auf der einen
Seite werden Rufe nach starken
Eingriffen des Staates laut, um Profitgier
und Verdrängung auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
zu beenden. Die andere Seite wiederum
ist sich sicher: hier kann nur der freie Markt
Lösungen finden. Bei 13 Fragen sind
sich meine Gäste wie immer erst mal nicht
einig. Umso spannender also, werden sie am Ende
der Folge dann doch einen Kompromiss
finden? Oder sich sogar auf eine Lösung
einigen können? Das werden wir am Ende
der Folge sehen. Was ist eure Meinung?
Auf welcher Seite würdet ihr stehen? Muss
der Staat stärker in den Wohnungsmarkt
eingreifen? Ja oder nein? Grün oder Gelb?
Vielleicht ändert sich eure Meinung
ja sogar im Verlauf der Folge. Dann gilt ab
jetzt für euch liebe Gäste, wenn ihr der anderen
Seite zustimmen wollt in einem
Argument, dann könnt ihr einen Schritt
auf die zugehen. Und wenn ihr vielleicht auch,
während jemand anders noch redet,
schon so sauer seid, dass ihr das irgendwie
körperlich zum Ausdruck bringen
wollt, dann könnt ihr einen Schritt nach hinten
gehen. Für mich ist natürlich das Ziel,
so viele wie möglich von euch hier am Ende
im Kompromissfeld zu sehen. Mal gucken,
ob das klappt. Dann geht's los. Sven mit dir.
Du hast 6 Jahre dafür gekämpft, dass du
mit deiner Familie in der Mietwohnung,
in der du wohnst und gewohnt hast,
bleiben kannst. Jetzt mittlerweile ist klar: Du
darfst da bleiben. Warum solltet
ihr da überhaupt raus?
Bei uns war es die klassische
Situation. Das Haus wurde verkauft, wurde
in Eigentumswohnungen umgewandelt und die Mieter
waren einfach im Weg. Dann kam
das volle Programm, fristlose
Kündigung, Räumungsklage et cetera pp. Und wir haben
uns dagegen gewehrt, einfach auch stellvertretend
für wirklich 100 000
andere in diesem Land, denen das Gleiche
widerfährt. Jeder steht immer einzeln
vor Gericht und muss für sein Recht
kämpfen. Und die Politik? Die sagt immer:
Ach aber wir haben doch hier
Regularien, die sind doch ausreichend. Nein! Die sind
es nicht, weil man wirklich als Mieter
schutzlos diesen teilweise physischen
und psychischen Repressalien
und Übergriffen ausgesetzt ist.
Auf dem Wohnungsmarkt muss sich
definitiv ändern, dass Menschen wieder geschützt
sind, dass sie einfach aus ihrem
Angstmodus rauskommen, ihre Wohnung
zu verlieren. Die Wohnung ist für mich
keine Ware, sondern einfach wirklich
die Grundbasis unserer Gesellschaft,
wo die Menschen einfach Sicherheit haben
und leben müssen.
Immobilienverwerter, die finden immer wieder Möglichkeiten,
die Mieter aus ihren Wohnungen
zu verdrängen und das ist für mich
das Problem. Und die Mieter sind in dem Moment
nicht Menschen, sondern es sind
einfach nur störende Objekte. Es braucht
eine Notbremse und wir haben ja jetzt
in der Pandemie gesehen, es geht, wenn die Regierung
und wenn die Politik willens
ist, etwas zu verändern, dann
bringt sie auch Sachen sehr schnell durch.
Und das ist meines Erachtens absolut
notwendig auf dem derzeitigen Mietmarkt,
um es wieder zu einem
Mietenmarkt zu machen.
Alle gehen einen Schritt auf ihn
zu. Babs, warum hast du dich bewegt?
Ja, also ich sehe das genauso wie Sven.
Es kann nicht sein, wenn die Mieter so lange
in der Wohnung drin wohnen, dass sie mit ihrer
Familie einfach rausgehen. Da bin
ich ganz bei Sven. Also für mich
der Hauptgrund, warum die Mieten steigen,
ist das Potenzial der Investoren, dass man
immer wieder die Immobilie sanieren muss,
renovieren muss. Alleine bei solchen
Investments kommen wirklich hohe
siebenstellige Beträge teilweise
zusammen und deshalb sind die Mieten auch so teuer,
da die Investmens irgendwann
natürlich auch zurückgeführt werden müssen.
Ich glaube persönlich, dass man die Muster
unterbrechen und sagen muss bisschen mehr
zum Eigentum rüber hinaus. Dass die Regierung
auch die Chance, die Möglichkeit
hat schaffen müssen, um bezahlbares
Wohnen in den Bereich Eigentum umzuwandeln.
Dass die Leute die Möglichkeit haben,
sich solche Wohnungen ganz einfach zu leisten.
Sven, du hast jetzt quasi schon fast
das Feld verlassen. Warum? Warum wolltest du
-so sehr an den Rand des Feldes?
-Ja, weil das für mich keine Lösung ist.
Also bei dem derzeit schon
explodierten Immobilienmarkt zu sagen: Warte mal,
ich kaufe meine Wohnung, damit ich da nicht
rausgeworfen werde, ist für mich
ein falscher Weg. Also ich sehe ja
in unserem Haus jetzt in den letzten drei
Jahren die Leute, die die Eigentumswohnung
gekauft haben, ihre Mieter reingesetzt
haben. Die Preise haben sich jetzt
fast verdoppelt. Das heißt, sie wollen
irgendwie ihre Wohnung für 10000 Euro
ein Quadratmeter kaufen. Das ist einfach nicht
leistbar. Und das ist auch nicht mein Ziel.
Für mich und meine Familie bedeutet
Freiheit einfach zu sagen: Ich habe
hier eine Mietwohnung. Ich möchte
eine bezahlbare Miete zahlen,
gerne an meinen Eigentümer, aber ich möchte
-die Wohnung nicht kaufen. Punkt.
-Maike, du bist auch einen Schritt auf Sven
-zugegangen.
-Ja, ich hadere gerade wieder ein bisschen.
Also ich gebe Babs total recht
und Sven, ich gebe dir auch total recht.
Diese Entmietungspraktiken, Häuser
aufzukaufen, um sie bewusst auch viel
zu teuer zu sanieren, um sie dann
bewusst an sehr wohlhabende Menschen verkaufen
zu wollen – das ist was, wo ich mich
absolut gegen positionieren möchte.
Der Kauf und die Vermietung
von Immobilien, gerade aus Sicht
einer Privatperson, aus Sicht
einer Selbstständigen, bietet absolut
die Chance, unabhängig im Alter zu sein,
finanzielle Sicherheit zu erlangen,
die eigene Rente zu erschaffen,
sich unabhängig zu machen vom Staat,
von staatlichen Systemen und wirklich
die volle Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Aber ich finde diese Haltung,
jemand anderes soll das finanzielle Risiko
tragen, jemand anderes soll im Prinzip
das Instandhaltungsrisiko tragen. Ich möchte
ja nur bezahlbar mieten. Ich persönlich
vermiete 8 Wohnungen und irgendwie muss
ich ja für mich dieses Risiko auch,
ich muss es ja händelbar haben, sozusagen,
dass du dich da als Mieter
klar ganz raus ziehst – schwierig.
An welcher Stelle habe ich gesagt,
dass ich mich also, über meine Miete will
ich das ja finanzieren. Aber
das klar ist, dass bei den derzeitigen
Immobiliengeschäften, bei den Verkäufen,
dass einfach mal so ne exorbitanten Preise
gezahlt werden, das klar ist: Über
eine Vermietung kann das überhaupt nicht
refinanziert werden. Das ist einfach
klar. Es geht nur über einen Verkauf und da muss
man einfach irgendjemanden finden,
der einfach noch mehr zahlt. Ich möchte
als Mieter natürlich dafür
aufkommen, aber was du beschreibst ist ja so
eine klassische Vermieterrolle und die gibt's
ja nun kaum noch. Also wenn du dich
da anständig verhältst: Glückwunsch.
Da komm ich auch bis in das Kompromissfeld
-zu dir, aber...
-Da kannst du gerne einen kleinen Schritt
-schon mal auf sie zugehen.
-Naja, wüsste ich jetzt gerade nicht, weil
-ich bin ja da gerade reingegrätscht.
-Maike hat sich einen Schritt auf dich
zubewegt. Babs, ich würde gern zu dir
kommen. Du hast dir in den letzten 15
Jahren ein kleines
Immobilienimperium aufgebaut. Du bist durch die Vermietung
von Wohnungen zu einer sogenannten
Selfmade-Millionärin geworden. Kannst du
-das vielleicht mal erklären?
-Ja, also ich hatte tatsächlich als
alleinerziehende Mama in der Spitze
fast 390 eigene Wohnungen und es war
tatsächlich so, dass es mehrere
Faktoren waren. Zum einen die steigende
Immobilienpreise der letzten 15 Jahre,
zum anderen die Möglichkeit, dass die Zinsen
immer weniger waren und die Tilgung
immer größer. Da entstand ein Delta des
Vermögens, des Nettovermögens. Das bedeutet,
dadurch ist es mir durchaus
gelungen, mein Immobilienportfolio so
groß zu halten, teilweise auch sehr schnell
runter zu tilgen. Wobei ich einen
Mieter-Durchschnittspreis angefangen haben
bei 3 Euro 48 und mittlerweile bewegen
wir uns bei den neu sanierten Wohnungen bei 9
Euro pro Quadratmeter. Ich bin
jetzt in Kassel, Mannheim, Heidelberg,
Rhein-Neckar-Kreis tätig gewesen,
war teilweise auch im Osten, wo die Mieten
relativ günstig waren. Also
Bautzen, Zittau näher zur tschechische Grenze
wieder rüber. Und da war das nicht so
brenzlig wie jetzt hier direkt in Berlin.
-Das muss man auch dazu sagen.
-Claudia, würdest du sagen, Babs ist Teil
-des Problems?
-Ich würde nicht sagen, sie ist Teil des
Problems, aber ich finde, was wir hier
diskutieren, verkennt ein bisschen,
was eigentlich das Problem ist. Die Wohnungsfrage
ist vor allem eine Mieter-
und Mieterinnenfrage in Deutschland.
Also Vorkaufsrecht schön und gut. Sven hat ja
gesagt, er will die Wohnung und er kann
die Wohnung auch gar nicht kaufen.
Für die meisten Menschen ist das einfach
so. Für sehr viele Menschen, gerade
auf dem Berliner Wohnungsmarkt und auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
in Großstädten ist
das überhaupt keine Option. Also
Menschen mit keinem oder geringem Einkommen,
die haben ein Riesenproblem, ihre Miete
zu zahlen. Eines der größten Probleme
für mich am deutschen Wohnungsmarkt
ist die Tatsache, dass sehr viele Menschen
ihr Recht auf angemessenen Wohnraum
nicht wahrnehmen können. Das betrifft z.B. sehr,
sehr viele Menschen, die wohnungslos
sind. In Deutschland reden wir hier von 300
bis 500 000 Menschen, die keinen
mietvertraglich abgesicherten Wohnraum
-haben.
-Emilene, du bist gerade einen Schritt
zurückgegangen. Du bist selbst
Sozialarbeiterin in Aachen und täglich
in Kontakt mit Jugendlichen, mit denen
konfrontiert, die in prekären
Lebenssituationen und zusammen mit ihren
Familien wohnen müssen. Welche Bedeutung
-hat denn Wohnraum eigentlich?
-Wohnraum ist Schutzraum vor allem für
Menschen, die rassifiziert sind,
die eine migrantische Biografie haben,
die Fluchterfahrung haben, Traumata.
All diese Dinge, die irgendwie ihren Alltag
eben auch beeinflussen. Und ich denke,
dass wir vor allem wenn wir über Wohnraum
sprechen, auch die soziale Frage
dahinter nicht vergessen dürfen. Diversität ist
aktuell nicht gewährleistet, weil es vor allem
auch marginalisierten Menschen,
Menschen mit migrantischem
Hintergrund beispielsweise sehr erschwert wird,
durch Rassismus überhaupt Wohnungen
zu finden. Viele an den Rand der Städte
ziehen müssen, um überhaupt bezahlbar
wohnen zu können und die Zugänge vor allem
auch in Innenstädten dann eben
privilegierten Gruppen überlassen wird.
Also ich finde, die Frage nach Zugang
zum Wohnraum ist eine extrem wichtige. Es gibt
ja ganz viele Gruppen in Deutschland,
die eben kein diskriminierungsfreien Zugang
zu Wohnraum haben. Also du hast
jetzt eine Gruppe angesprochen. Ich forsche
zu wohnungslosen Menschen. Also
versucht mal mit letzter Meldeadresse Haftanstalt
oder letzter Meldeadresse städtische
Obdachlosenunterkunft, was übrigens extrem
viele Menschen in Deutschland
betrifft, irgendwie eine Wohnung zu bekommen
auf dem heiß umkämpften Wohnungsmarkt.
Aber selbst wenn es Wohnungen geben würde,
wären die Menschen nicht diejenigen,
die die Wohnungen bekommen würden. Also
ich denke, gerade wenn wir über
diskriminierungsfreien Zugang
zum Wohnungsmarkt reden,
muss auf jeden Fall etwas passieren.
Diskriminierungsfreier Zugang zu Wohnraum
in Deutschland. Würdet ihr da einen
Schritt auf Emileneund Claudia
zugehen? Also dass es ein System gibt,
in dem Rassismus auch eine große
Rolle spielt?
Ja, da geb ich dir recht, dass ich zu den wenigen
Vermietern gehören, die das so
-sehen, ja.
-Michael, auch du hast dich bewegt. Warum?
Ja, ich denke, das können wir nicht
leugnen. Es gibt Diskriminierung am Markt
und es gibt bessere und schlechtere
Vermieter:innen im System. Ich sehe
das auch so. Dort dominiert
Wettbewerb und Profitinteresse und von daher ja
auch Diskriminierung. Die Lösungen,
die wir brauchen, die haben gleichzeitig
mit sozialen sowie ökologischen
Aspekten zu tun. Das heißt, wir müssen günstig
bauen, auch mit kleineren Wohnungen
auskommen. Und das geht nur, wenn Leute
es verstehen und unterstützen
wollen. Deswegen müssen die Lösungen eben
-aus der Bevölkerung kommen.
-Emilene, wenn wir jetzt den Wohnungsmarkt
hauptsächlich dem freien Markt
überlassen würden, würde dann diese soziale
Durchmischung überhaupt noch
stattfinden, die du angesprochen hast?
Ich glaube das nicht, weil es eben
um diese soziale Frage geht. Und die kann
nur tatsächlich durch eine Unterstützung
vom Staat auch umgesetzt werden.
Und das eben auch strukturell. Und wenn der Staat
sich da völlig rauszieht,
haben wir ja auch gar keine
richtige Basis, um zu entscheiden
und um strukturelle
Änderungen eben auch einsetzen zu können.
Also sagst du: Der Staat hat da eine sehr große,
eine wichtige Rolle
und auch eine große
Verantwortung. Maike, wie siehst du das?
Ja, das denke ich auch. Ich denke
sowas wie Auflagen, wie viel soziale Wohnungen
in Neubauprojekte mit entstehen
müssen, die Auflagen, die es ja auch heute schon
gibt, die sind absolut
berechtigt und auch total angebracht.
Babs, sind denn dann
die Investoren das Problem?
Also ich glaube nicht, dass nur die Investoren
ein Problem darstellen.
Man muss die Investoren
auch unterscheiden. Ich gehöre eher
zu den Buy-and-hold-Königinnen,
wo ich sage: Okay, ich kauf, ich werde
das auch renovieren und halte das in Stand
mit meinen Mietern. Und wenn wir erhöhen,
dann erhöhen wir klein, 50 Euro,
vielleicht einmal in drei Jahren. Und ja,
natürlich habe ich schon gesagt
bekommen: Ja, euer Mietpotenzial ist ja riesig.
Aber ich habe Leute drin, die wohnen
seit 1978 in der Wohnung, ich glaube nicht,
dass meine ältesten Mieterinnen sich
dann 12 Euro, 13 Euro oder 15 Euro leisten
können und deshalb mache ich es nicht,
weil: es geht mir auch so gut. Das muss
-ich dazu sagen.
-Ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich wie Babs
sagt. Wer mit Wohnraum spekulieren
möchte, der darf eigentlich aus meiner Sicht
am Markt nicht agieren. Weil Wohnraum
ist kein Spekulationsgut, ist auch für mich
kein Spekulationsgut. Ich kaufe
die Wohnungen, um sie lange zu behalten.
Für mich ist das meine Altersvorsorge.
Wir haben auch ein marodes Rentensystem
und das geht aus meiner Perspektive
mit langfristigen und guten Verhältnissen
zu Mietern und Mieterinnen und Spekulationen
auf Preissteigerungen,
Leerstand herbeizuführen, auf unbebaute
Objekte zu spekulieren. Das ist
eine Geschichte, wo ich finde,
da kann ein Staat auch eingreifen.
Auf Wohnraum darf nicht spekuliert
werden. Da sind ja alle einen Schritt nach vorne
gegangen. Claudia, warum bist
du einen Schritt nach vorne gegangen?
Ich bin ein Schritt nach vorne
gegangen, weil ich Maike völlig zustimme. Es ist
einfach eine Frage von Recht und Pflicht.
Deutschland ist zur Umsetzung
von internationalen
Menschenrechtsverträgen verpflichtet,
weil es die ratifiziert hat. Und dazu
gehört auch das Recht auf Wohnen.
Das heißt, der Staat muss das Recht
auf bezahlbares und angemessenes Wohnen
für alle gewährleisten und ein Baustein
ist eben sowas zu unterbinden.
Ich glaube, dass die Politik andere
Lösungsansätze schaffen muss, für die ganz
normalen Leute, für die ganz
normalen Mieter, Wohnraum zu erreichen. Aber
unter anderen Bedingungen.
Steuerbegünstigungen, einfach billigere
Kredite geben und das ist dann
zukünftig auch für unsere Kinder. Gerade
die Migrationskinder sind doch die Kinder,
die in Deutschland zukünftig aufbauen
werden oder nach wie vor wirtschaftlich
dafür sorgen, dass wir, wenn es überhaupt
-noch Rente geben wird, eine Rente haben.
-Ich denke, wir müssen unbedingt
differenzieren zwischen privaten
profitinteressierten Investoren und Bau-
und Wohngenossenschaften, die tendenziell
in der Gemeinwohlorientierungsecke sich
befinden. Das macht einen
Riesenunterschied. Der Staat hat eben
Spielregeln fest zu halten. Und da bin
ich also zunächst nicht für staatliche
Lösungen. Aber der Staat sollte doch
sagen können: Eine Mehrheit von der Nation
sollte bitteschön eine Wohnung
finden, auch bezahlbar,
auch in einer Nachbarschaft,
wo die gerne wohnen. Und da sind
die Gemeinwohlorientierten, also die Bau-
und Wohngenossenschaft nicht mit privaten
-und provitorientierten zu vergleichen.
-Emilene, du bist auch einen Schritt auf
-Michael zugegangen.
-Ja, ich bin auch auf Michael zugegangen.
Und zwar ist es auch so, dass wir mit unserem
Jugendzentrum in einem alten
Brauerei-Komplex auch unseren Ort
gefunden haben und da auch unser Zuhause haben.
Und da funktioniert das halt genau
so, dass der Vermieter eben auch einen
sehr großen Sinn für Gemeinwohl hat
und auch sieht, wie wichtig es ist, eben
auch Orte zu schaffen, in denen
Menschen sich begegnen können und zusammenkommen
können. Und das funktioniert
auch sehr gut. Ich weiß aber eben auch,
dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt
Paradebeispiel für überall in Deutschland
ist. Ich denke aber, wenn solche
Prozesse oder Strukturen eben auch staatlich
gefördert werden würden, dass das auch einfach
flächendeckender wirken könnte.
Maike, du besitzt einige Immobilien,
bist also Vermieterin und du coacht sogar
auch Frauen zum Thema Altersvorsorge
durch Immobilienkauf. Welche Gefahr siehst du
denn jetzt, wenn der Staat in den Wohnungsmarkt
eingreifen würde?
Also es kommt ja auf die Frage an,
wie der Staat eingreifen würde. Was für mich
natürlich schwierig oder problematisch
ist, ist, wenn wir über die Einnahmenseite
sprechen, also über die Mieteinnahmenseite,
weil ich ich denke
langfristig. Ich finanziere über 30
Jahre, das soll am Ende, wenn ich in Rente gehe,
soll es im Prinzip meinen
Lebensunterhalt bezahlen. Und wenn ich dann
auf der Einnahmenseite im Prinzip
nicht kalkulieren kann, weil das ein riesen
Fragezeichen ist, dann ist das für mich
schwierig. Also eine staatliche
Regulierung kann ich mir eher
vorstellen. Wie und wo wollen wir Wohnraum schaffen?
Welche Wohnkonzepte wollen wir fördern?
Aber diese Mietendeckel, Mietenbegrenzung,
Mietenstopp-Diskussionen
deutschlandweit, das ist für mich etwas, was mir einfach
-die Planung erschwert.
-Sven, kannst du das verstehen, dass das
Maike die Planung
erschwert und dass sie das stört?
Ja, kann ich absolut verstehen. Ich meine,
ich bin auch Unternehmer. Also ich weiß
auch, dass man damit Einnahmen
und Ausgaben hätte. Ja, keine Frage.
Aber irgendwo muss man trotzdem
einfach mal sagen: Warte mal, es muss
was passieren. Wir müssen Bild
nach außen erzeugen. Das einfach wirklich
diese ganzen Spekulanten, die wir ja
jetzt schon mal gemeinsam mit Übel und Problem
festgestellt haben, dass die einfach
abgeschreckt werden. Und da sind natürlich
so eine Diskussion, wie das hier
eingeführt wurde und der Meitendeckel
und diese Demos und alles,
was zum Widerstand in dieser Stadt
gegen Verdrängung mit den Ressourcen
führt, finde ich erzeugt Bilder, die Leute
-abschrecken sollten. Bestenfalls.
-Claudia, du arbeitest am Institut für
Menschenrechte und stehst auch im engen
Austausch mit wohnungslosen Menschen,
auch mit Politiker:innen. Was passiert
denn mit den Verlierer:innen
dieses Wohnungsmarktsystems und warum verlieren
die ihre Wohnungen?
Ganz viele wohnungslose Menschen
leben auf der Straße. Sie wohnen auf dem Sofa,
bei Bekannten oder Freunden. Das betrifft
vor allem wohnungslose Frauen
und vor allem ganz viele wohnen in den kommunalen
Wohnungslosenunterkünften.
Und wir reden hier wirklich von großen
Zahlen. Also in Berlin sind das 35 000
Leute, in Nordrhein-Westfalen
sind das ungefähr 30 000 Menschen,
die in den kommunalen
Wohnungslosenunterkünften wohnen und davon
ein Viertel Kinder. Und diese Menschen
wohnen dort auf engstem Raum,
teilweise nicht immer, aber unter absolut
menschenunwürdigen Bedingungen und haben
auch keine Chance, wieder eine Wohnung
auf dem normalen Wohnungsmarkt zu bekommen.
Eben weil sie, selbst wenn es Wohnungen
gibt, sind sie die Allerletzten, die dafür
in Frage kommen. Das heißt, sie bleiben
teilweise auf Monate und Jahre
-in diesen kommunalen Unterkünften.
-Ich glaube, was auch noch ein wichtiger
Aspekt ist: Diese Traumatisierung
der Menschen. Egal, ob du einen
Entmietungskampf führst, egal, ob du
ihn gewinnst oder ob du verlierst, du wirst
einfach traumatisiert. Und die psychosozialen
Kosten am Ende
auch für unsere Gesellschaft zu sagen:
Warte mal, diese Menschen, ob sie dann
irgendwo eine Wohnung finden,
ob die im Heim landen, die Kinder
von diesen Menschen – also egal wie,
die kriegen eine Klatsche fürs Leben weg.
Du legst dich schlafen mit dem Grundgesetz
unterm Kopfkissen und sagst einfach:
Die Wohnung ist unverletzlich. Und dann
wachst du aus dem Dornröschenschlaf
auf und merkst einfach: aber das ist
die Realität. Die Wohnung ist schon lange
nicht mehr unverletzlich. Heißt: Ich kann
mir nicht sicher sein, dass ich morgen,
heute meine Wohnung noch habe. Ich habe
im Laufe der letzten Jahre so viele Menschen
kennengelernt, die wirklich in permanenter
Angst leben. Und ich finde, das geht so
-einfach nicht.
-Claudia, Stichwort permanente Angst. Wie
ist denn die Perspektive? Werden
noch mehr Menschen ihre Wohnungen verlieren?
Mit was können wir denn da rechnen
für eine Entwicklung?
Ich habe natürlich keine Glaskugel, wo ich in die Zukunft
schauen kann. Aber ich sehe
schon schwarz, wenn nicht
der Staat stärker eingreift
und die Rahmenbedingungen dafür
setzt, dass Wohnen bezahlbar bleibt für alle
Menschen und dass die Menschen auch unter menschenwürdigen
Bedingungen wohnen
können. Also ich möchte gerne auch auf einen
Punkt eingehenden, den Sven gesagt
hat, sie wachen früh mit der Angst
auf und vielleicht bleiben sie dann
auch in der Wohnung, obwohl sie eigentlich
schon die Miete gar nicht mehr stemmen
können. Also die Mietbelastungenquote,
die Frage, wie viel ich von meinem Einkommen
ausgebe für die Miete, die ist gerade
bei Haushalten mit wenig Einkommen extrem
hoch. Die geben teilweise 30, 40
Prozent des Einkommens für die Miete aus.
Da bleibt nicht mehr viel übrig am Ende
des Monats. Also das ist wirklich
eine Frage von Existenzangst,
so wie du das geschildert hast.
Michael, du bist der erste, der im Kompromissfeld
mit einem halben Fuß
-gelandet ist.
-Ich komme diesen Mitteilungen oder
Aussagen entgegen, weil ich bin nicht
für die staatlichen Lösung, aber ich finde,
wir brauchen Notlösungen oder Notbremsen.
In dem Sinne sehe ich Mietendeckel,
aber eigentlich auch die Enteignungsinitiative
als konstruktiv,
dass wir darüber reden, dass wir uns
überhaupt Gedanken machen. Und eigentlich
ist die Enteignunginitiative nur da wegen Investoren
oder Eigentümern, die mehr
als 3000 Einheiten haben. Das heißt, es betrifft
nicht Menschen mit zehn Einheiten
oder hundert oder selbst
eintausend Einheiten. Es fängt mit den zehn,
fünfzehn in Berlin an, die mehr als 3000
haben. Deswegen kann ich damit gut leben
und sagen: Ja, es ist eine Krise,
wir müssen eigentlich den Menschen
entgegenkommen, die gestresst sind
oder die schon obdachlos sind oder damit
-bedroht. Das finde ich korrekt.
-Emilene, ich sehe auch bei dir zwei halbe
Füße im Kompromissfeld. Warum bist
du gerade einen Schritt auf Michael
-zugegangen?
-Ja, definitiv, da kann ich definitiv auch
zustimmen. Vor allem auch, dass es einfach
neue Lösungen braucht. Jetzt eskaliert
es in Berlin, aber das Problem besteht
ja nicht erst seit gestern, sondern schon
einfach super super lange. Was ich aber
auch nochmal sagen möchte und das hattest
du eben auch gesagt, dass diese Konzepte
aber auch von unterschiedlichen
Gesellschaftsgruppen gestaltet
werden können oder müssen. Es bringt nichts,
wenn Menschen, die sowieso in einem
Kiez oder einem Viertel leben, sich zusammentun
und diese Konzepte erarbeiten. Sondern eben
auch mit anderen Menschen aus anderen
Stadtgebieten, vielleicht auch eher
aus der Grenze oder außerhalb der Innenstadt
zusammenkommen und daran arbeiten.
Und alle aber auch gleichberechtigt sind
darin, um wirklich neue
Ideen erschaffen zu können.
Ich glaube, darum geht es, dass wir verstehen,
wir sind die Leute,
die die Zukunft und die Gesellschaft
gestalten, nicht irgendjemand.
Aus dieser Verantwortung kann sich
niemand rausziehen. Und das ist wirklich wichtig,
dass wir auch nicht mit der Forderung
zu sagen, die Politik muss etwas regulieren.
Ich ziehe mich da nicht aus der Verantwortung.
Ich bin mittendrin
und das muss, glaube ich, wirklich
jeder verstehen, dass er an der Stelle
mit den Ressourcen, die er hat,
irgendwie die Welt vielleicht an dem Tag
ein bisschen besser macht. Und dann,
finde ich, ist es jetzt schon in Ordnung.
Dann habe ich einen
Kompromissvorschlag an euch. Mal sehen, ob ihr einen Schritt
auf mich zugeht. Ihr seid ja alle
schon sehr nah dran am Kompromissfeld oder fast
drin. Also können wir uns alle
darauf einigen, dass Wohnraum kein
Spekulationsgut ist. Alle gehen
einen Schritt auf mich zu. Babs ein bisschen
zögerlich. Warum so einen
kleinen, zögerlichen Schritt nur?
Also ich bin definitiv nicht
gegen Spekulanten. Was man sehen muss,
dass tatsächlich die Investoren die sind,
die die Innenstädte schöner gemacht haben.
Wenn natürlich damit spekuliert wird,
in der Form, was dir widerfahren ist, ist
-es absolut nicht akzeptabel.
-Dann lass uns gerne zu den Lösungen
kommen. Ihr könnt jetzt nämlich
jeweils auf jeder Seite des Feldes, einmal
die grüne Seite, einmal die gelbe
Seite, die Köpfe zusammenstecken
wie in der Schulgruppenarbeit. Ihr habt
jetzt ein paar Minuten Zeit und könnt euch
einen konkreten Vorschlag
überlegen, den ihr der anderen Seite dann gleich
präsentiert. Und ihr könnt
ruhig überlegen, es kann natürlich
eine politische Forderung sein, es kann
aber auch wirklich eine konkrete Maßnahme
sein. Also seid da gerne
kreativ. Dann geht's los, würde ich sagen.
Was für Erfahrungen habt ihr denn
mit staatlichen Maßnahmen gemacht?
Welche funktionieren, welche
funktionieren gar nicht? Schreibt's gerne mal
in die Kommentare. Ihr seid alle
ready? Sehr gut. Dann würde ich jetzt mit euch,
der grünen Seite,
anfangen. Was habt ihr euch überlegt?
Also wir haben jetzt keine klaren
Forderungen, sondern eher so eine Art
gemeinsames Bekenntniss, wo wir glauben,
dass wir da sehr gut in einem Boot sitzen
können und uns nicht rausschubsen. Es geht
um den sozialen Frieden in den nächsten
Jahren. Und ich glaube, dass unser gemeinsames
Interesse ist, wenn wir jetzt
zwei Seiten haben - wir auf der Mieterseite,
ihr als Vermieter
oder als Eigentümer - dass wir uns
einfach gemeinsam positionieren
gegen diese seelenlosen
Spekulanten, die dafür sorgen, dass in diesem Land
die Sozialsituation immer brenzliger
wird. Dass es wirklich eine extreme Anspannung
gibt und dass am Ende, wenn es hier
wirklich richtig knallt, weil die Menschen
nichts mehr zu verlieren haben, dass dann
keinem von uns geholfen ist. Am Ende
wollen wir doch alle das Gleiche:
Wir wollen in Frieden leben. Wir wollen,
dass unsere Kinder gesund sind, dass die Welt
weiter besteht und dass wir irgendwie
-miteinander klarkommen.
-Maike, was hat dich gerade daran
-überzeugt?
-Ja, ich glaube, das hat Sven schon ganz
gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Natürlich
geht es irgendwie um ein soziales Zusammenleben
in Deutschland aus Eigentümer_innenperspektive
und Mieter_innenperspektive. So wie du
es jetzt beschrieben hast, ist es was,
-wo ich zustimmen mag.
-Ja, das hört sich gut an. Es ist
vielleicht ein bisschen Konflikt
vermeiden, aber es ist gut, daran erinnert
zu werden, worum geht's uns
eigentlich hier im Leben? Ja, wir sollten das Leben
genießen. Also die Leute sollten
wenig Stress haben und sollten eine Wohnung
-finden können als gemeinsamer Nennner.
-Dann möchte ich euch, die gelbe Seite,
jetzt gerne fragen: Was für ein Kompromissvorschlag
habt ihr euch
-überlegt?
-Also der Punkt ist - ich hoffe, ich kann
das sagen - von uns aus gesehen, quasi
vom Staat aus vom Volk über die Verwaltung
und Politik bezahlbare Wohnungen zu fördern
bzw. bauen zu lassen. Das heißt
weniger zu bestrafen und mehr zu fördern.
Wenn wir Bauherren, Investoren,
Genossenschaften kennen,
finden, entwickeln lassen, dann sollten
wir die fördern, wenn die uns damit
helfen, Wohnungen bezahlbar herzustellen
-und langfristig zu verwalten.
-Reicht dieser Kompromissvorschlag aus,
-damit ihr auch hier Kompromissfeld landet?
-Also in die Richtung, in die er geht: Ja.
Aber einfach mal in der aktuellen
Situation, in der wir uns gerade befinden:
Nein. Wir haben hier eine Situation,
die lässt sich mit "wir bauen und wir machen
alles schön und mit grünen Wiesen"
nicht mehr lösen. Es brennt hier schon,
die Leute verlassen reihenweise die Stadt,
haben sie in den letzten 10 Jahren.
Also das heißt, wir sind mittendrin
und da ist einfach ein bisschen zu nett,
zu perspektivisch und zu Eiapopeia
gedacht. Hier ist wirklich Kampf,
Brutalität und wirklich Gewalt an der Tagesordnung
bei der Verdrängung
von Mietern. Und da ist es aus meiner
Sicht nicht ausreichend.
Claudia, dir war es nicht zu Friede,
Freude, Eierkuchen, denn du bist einen
-Schritt auf die andere Seite zugegangen.
-Ich finde den Kompromissvorschlag gut.
Letztlich geht es ja doch darum,
dass der Staat Rahmenbedingungen schafft.
Und euer Vorschlag ist ja, dass er nicht
straft, sondern dass positiv Anreize
geschaffen werden. Und da kann
man ja über viele Sachen nachdenken,
Belegungsindung und was weiß ich was,
Investitionsförderung. Deshalb finde
ich den Vorschlag gut. Also ich sehe
das als eine von den möglichen Lösungen.
Ich kann jetzt das erste Mal
seit acht Jahren wieder ruhig schlafen,
weil ich weiß, es gibt solche
Vermieter. Und wenn ich irgendwann auf dem Berliner
Wohnungsmarkt meine Wohnung verliere,
bin ich nicht obdachlos, sondern kann einfach
zu dir gehen. Also dass es einfach
die klassischen Vermieter noch gibt,
-darüber freue ich mich sehr.
-Ich hab gelernt, dass der Brennpunkt
dessen, dass Mieter hier gerade in Berlin,
dass der Markt so angespannt ist, was mir
vielleicht überhaupt nicht bewusst
war, dass mit solcher Brutalität die Vermieter
ihren Mietern letztendlich
entgegentreten. Und das war für mich teilweise
schockierend. Niemand soll sich dem Gegenüber
einfach so verhalten. Und eins
ist klar, da sollte tatsächlich der Staat
vielleicht eine Forderung erschaffen
für uns Investoren, die dann
bezahlbaren Wohnraum kaufen, renovieren, sanieren
-und dann Mietern zur Verfügung stellen.
-Gerade aktuell im Wahljahr würde ich mir
wünschen, dass das Grundrecht
auf Wohnen viel mehr verankert wird
in einer politischen Agenda, dass viel
mehr Parteien das wirklich als eine ihrer
Grundprinzipien aufnehmen und dabei
die Menschen, die vor allem davon betroffen
sind und zwar die Mieter_innen
mit einbezogen werden in den Prozess.
Dann danke ich euch
vielmals für die Diskussion.
-Ich danke dir. Danke.
-Ich denke, die Diskussion hat ganz gut
gezeigt, dass es natürlich nicht die eine Lösung
dafür gibt, wie wir in Zukunft
bezahlbaren Wohnraum für alle
haben können, es braucht mehrere Maßnahmen
und dafür muss die Diskussion
natürlich weitergeführt werden. Das könnt ihr z.B.
gerne in den Kommentaren tun.
Vielleicht hat euch diese Folge 13 Fragen ja sogar
dazu angeregt. Dann lasst sehr gerne
auch ein Abo für diesen Kanal. Hier oben könnt
ihr ein weiteres Video 13 Fragen
anschauen und hier unten ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.